we can't help our thoughts I don't
believe in free will like so anything
that you do or think like you can't you
really can't control it and there's no
there's no dispute you you can't control
your thoughts so like you're not
responsible for them so I let myself off
the hook for the things that I think and
that actually really helped me with my
standup because I was able to start
talking about things on stage that I
really was like so ashamed of I have a
bit about like when young beautiful
women die like I love it yeah less
competition yeah like I I like it like
I'm not like actively killing them or
hoping they die but when there's a
pretty girl that has passed who's
younger than me I'm kind of like all
right well I'm not like I'm not you know
celebrating it there's a sick part of me
that's like if someone has to die I'd
rather it be a beautiful young girl sure
for sure